Alice uh another round another Victory
that's a hatrick for you after a slow
start first of all congratulations your
emotions right
now um yeah I'm very happy with this
game especially since I feel like um out
of the opening I didn't really get much
and I was okay with the draw uh so I
definitely like winning was a really uh
great for me um and yeah because I defin
it definitely was like she was the one
who was like kind of slightly pushing um
but then something happened and I
thought then it became like easier for
me to play um and it was really nice to
be able to win at what point did you
feel like things are getting easier for
you to
play um so I would say uh so when she
played like Bishop takes uh D7 or when
she took my um one of my minor pieces uh
and then she allowed me to like take her
Bishop back instead of taking her KN it
was like Bishop takes D4 I don't know it
was around uh somewhere around here
take take Bishop takes F6 once you got
the two
Bishops yeah okay so uh after uh Bishop
F3 Bishop A5 and she took my Bishop um I
thought because if she play Knight C4
I'd probably play like Rook C8 and just
go I was ping that to then like uh uh I
mean I was I didn't have to immediately
take the night but I thought then at
some point I probably would end up
taking the Knight so it just be uh a
draw after just a draw yeah after she
played Bishop takes D5 I'm assuming it
probably it still probably had to be a
draw um but I thought then it became
easier for me because my Rook is active
and yeah so here I knew like this this I
went upon um but of course it's very
hard for her to play uh and defend this
endan and eventually in time trouble I
think um she made a few mistakes it
wasn't easy but you managed to grind her
down in this one congratulations Alice
uh big big game big streak for you and
it seems like things are finally working
your way once again in this tournament
great to see you in great
shape thank you see you tomorrow AB